-Our next guest can be seen
at the Dead Crow Comedy Room
in Wilmington,
North Carolina,
this Friday and Saturday.
Making her "Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome the very funny
Sophie Buddle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey. Hello.
Thank you so much.
Hi, everybody.
I'm really happy to be here.
I'm happy to be in the country.
I'm Canadian. I just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, Canadian?
Or you just love peace?
[ Laughter ]
Fan of peacefulness.
That's cool.
Yeah. I'm Canadian.
I moved to America this year.
I wanted to see it
before it ends.
[ Laughter ]
Just sort of a bucket list
thing for me.
[ Laughter ]
And I moved to L.A.
I moved to Los Angeles,
which is --
It's what you think it's like.
it's weird, right?
Like, the people there are
weird. I've never met people
who actually say stuff out loud
in real life before.
Like, "Do you know
who my father is?"
[ Laughter ]
And to be honest with you,
I do also say that,
but only because my dad
hasn't really opened up
to me like that.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm just trying to see
if he talked to anybody else.
[ Laughter ]
I will be honest with you.
This was not my dream.
No offense, Jim.
[ Laughter ]
You have a lovely home
and many root.
[ Laughter ]
So many root.
But this was not my dream.
This is not what I wanted
for myself. When I was little,
I really was hoping that
I was going to become a spy.
[ Laughter ]
It didn't work out for me.
I stand on stage.
I tell secrets
into a microphone,
so it's not really what
they're looking for right now.
But I remember
just being a little kid
and staying up late at night
and being like,
"I hope when I grow up,
I'm hot enough to be a spy."
[ Laughter ]
Because I just want to be
the best spy I could be.
And we all know from movies
and TV shows,
the best spies are hot.
And they did a somersault
and they're wearing leather.
And you're like, "That's
impossible. That's amazing.
[ Laughter ]
Still got it.
So I thought you had to be hot
to be a spy.
But I actually realized
as an adult woman,
you would make a much
more effective spy
if you're really frumpy-looking
because if you're all hot
and you're trying to break
into some big organization,
you're going to get there
and the security guard
is going to have
so many questions for you.
"How's it going?"
Like, grilling her.
But if you're all frumpy
and you show up and you're like,
"I have to do this paperwork,"
he's like, "Ew, fine. Go."
[ Laughter ]
"Get in the vault. Hurry."
Nobody's more invisible
in our society than like
an average-looking woman.
And if that's offensive to you,
I can't see you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I still do try
to make spy stuff
happen in my life as an adult.
Like, I go through
my boyfriend's phone.
[ Laughter ]
And then I do a somersault. Wah!
But for real, the spy thing
that I think is really cool
that nobody really gives credit
to is the facial recognition
technology on our phones.
It's awesome.
It's spy stuff, right?
You hold your phone
up to your face
and it scans your face
or something and that opens up
and you can just hold up
your boyfriend's phone
to his face
when he's sleeping, obviously.
[ Laughter ]
You just hold it up.
It feels like an oversight.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes you do have to open up
their eyelids a little bit, but.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Oh, you're
dreaming."
[ Laughter ]
"Go back to sleep."
But I do actually think
this facial recognition
technology is really cool,
but it has a really
bad reputation.
Like, whenever you look into it,
everyone's always like,
"Ooh, you know the government's
actually using this
to look at us. Ooh, the
government's using that.
Government's not going
to get my face."
And it's like it's always guys
that are freaking out
about the government
watching us and I don't care.
[ Laughter ]
Girls don't care.
And I think the reason that is,
is we're used to being looked at
when we don't want
to be looked at.
That's just part
of our lives.
But it's apparently
never happened to a man,
even one time, once.
[ Laughter ]
They're freaking out.
The government's --
They're making a documentary.
They're writing a novel.
They can't believe it.
"The government
is looking at me."
And so I think what
the government should do
is I think the government
should like put out a statement
to these guys just being
like, "Smile, gorgeous."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"Take the compliment, babe."
Like, you know, when we get
all covered up in public
so nobody harasses us in public?
That's the same as when guys
put a little piece of tape
on their webcam.
I just wish it was
that easy for us.
If a guy's looking at you
and you feel uncomfortable,
you should be allowed
to go up to him
and put a little bit
of tape on his eyes.
Okay, I'm Sophie Buddle.
Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness.
Thank you so much.
Sophie Buddle!
[ Cheers and applause ]
See Sophie this Friday
and Saturday
at the Dead Crow Comedy Room
in Wilmington,
North Carolina.
We'll be right back,
everybody.